bonjour mesdames et messieurs merci de
vous être connecté ou d'être ici avec
nous pour ce point de presse de la
mission d'information évaluation des
effets du confinement
aujourd'hui bernard jomier président de
la mission commune d'information
évaluation des mesures en matière de
confinement est exceptionnellement
rapporteur car la mission avait décidé
de confier à la mairesse maladies
infectieuses émergentes la réalisation
d'une étude sur ce que pourrait être la
suite de la lutte contre la pandémie
chacun se rend compte depuis quelques
jours de la menace que peut faire peser
sur notre pays le variant delta et par
conséquent il était utile que notre
mission se penche sur comment prévenir
comment assurer la suite des opérations
sans retomber dans le confinement ou les
mesures restrictives que nous avons
connu par le passé je donne tout de
suite la parole au président rapporteur
bernard jomier merci roger karoutchi
pour cette introduction
bonjour à toutes et à tous je voudrais
vous rappeler donc en introduction que
la mission commune d'information a été
mise en place suite à une volonté du
président du sénat gérard larcher
partagé par l'ensemble des groupes
politiques afin que le sénat exerce sa
mission de contrôle de l'exécutif et de
prospective sur la suite de la pandémie
due qu'aux vide 19
nous nous sommes constitués au mois de
février mars et dès la constitution de
la mission sur la question qui est
l'objet de ce rapport que nous
présentons aujourd'hui nous avions
nous faisons le constat que au mois de
mai juin la france disposerait
probablement de vaccin en quantité que
la population pourrait accéder donc de
façon large à la vaccination ce qui
n'était pas le cas quand nous avons
constitué la mission est qu une question
se poserait alors qui serait celle de la
suite de la gestion de l'épidémie car
deux scénarios pouvait être envisagé un
premier où la vaccination se déploierait
suffisamment pour que combinée à au
nombre de personnes qui ont contracté le
virus et qui ont une protection
naturelle on atteigne un seuil
d'immunité collectif et puis un autre
scénario qui nous paraissaient
malheureusement probable qu'ils aient
que la vaccination soit insuffisamment
diffusées et que le seuil d'immunité
collective ne soit pas atteint
évidemment nous avions besoin d'avoir
des modélisations mathématiques
épidémiologistes et une analyse de santé
publique pour comprendre ce qui pourrait
se passer
et s'il fallait à ce moment-là aller
vers de nouvelles mesures pour une
réduction plus forte de la circulation
du virus
nous avons donc demandé à l'agencé
nationale maladies infectieuses
émergentes de mener cette étude en
collaboration avec le cnrs l'inserm et
l'institut pasteur et c'est les
résultats cette étude qui ont été
divulguées par l'institut pasteur
il y a quelques jours cette étude nous
apprend et nous nous confirme des points
tout à fait essentielle
le premier qui est largement dans
l'actualité c'est qu'une quatrième vague
en nombre de cas est probable d'ici deux
à trois mois et que cette quatrième
vague sera alimentée mai
les projections montrent qu'elles
auraient lieu de toute façon sera
alimenté par la contagiosité plus
importantes du variant delta qui est
apparue elle aurait eu lieu parce que de
toute façon sur la pente actuelle de la
vaccination
nous n'atteindrons pas le seuil
d'immunité collective dans les
prochaines semaines ou dans les deux à
trois mois à venir et donc différents
scénarii ont été étudiées par les
modélisateurs et qui nous démontre et ça
c'est un point qui est absolument
fondamental que dans l'hypothèse moyenne
et bien cette vague provoquera un afflux
dans les hôpitaux tout à fait comparable
à celui de l'automne dernier c'est à
dire que ça ne serait pas contrairement
à ce qu'on pouvait peut-être espérer une
vague de cas bénins qui surviendrait
uniquement ce donc sur des gens jeunes
en bon état de santé qui ne ferait pas
de forme grave
et bien non ça n'est potentiellement pas
le scénario qui risque de se passer
il ya donc à laisser la pente actuelle
se poursuivre à la fois un risque
sanitaire bien sûr le risque d'une
surcharge des hôpitaux de nombreuses
formes sévères de l'infection qu'ovide
mais il ya aussi un risque économique et
social parce que quand on regarde cette
cette situation si on aboutit c'est
évidemment au même scénario qu'à
l'automne dernier eh bien il faudrait
prendre des mesures de restrictions très
importantes qui auraient un impact
économique social sur notre vie
culturelle que l'on connaît il aurait là
un impact sur la scolarité des enfants
et c'est tout cela qui évidemment nous
voulons éviter est donc le premier point
très important c'est que
nous demandons qu'une stratégie de
circulation minimale du virus soit mise
en place
il faut restreindre beaucoup plus
fortement la circulation du virus
nous n'éviterons pas dans ce schéma là
une reprise des cas mais nous
transformerons la vague en vaguelettes
et nous éviterons des mesures de
nouvelles mesures restrictives
nous éviterons des conséquences pour la
scolarité des enfants nous éviterons des
conséquences pour nos hôpitaux
donc c'est absolument fondamental
d'avoir cette stratégie de circulation
minimale mise en application
c'est un enjeu pour notre pays et nous
disons aussi que c'est un enjeu
vis-à-vis des autres pays car une france
qui présenteraient une circulation
élevée du virus ou moyenne par rapport à
d'autres pays qui préserve une
circulation beaucoup plus faible dans le
contexte de la reprise des activités
économiques du tourisme des transports
internationaux et bien autres pays
risquerait d'apparaître comme un pays
peu sûr que certaines activités et vitré
que les touristes continuerait par
exemple à éviter la bonne nouvelle
la bonne nouvelle de cette étude et d de
l'analyse santé publique qu'elle porte
c'est qu'il il est possible de réduire
fortement le risque de cette de cette
vague de réduire ce risque de vagues
fortes pardon et il est possible
d'éviter de nouvelles mesures
restrictives et la saturation des
hôpitaux
mais pour cela et c'est tout à fait
fondamental il faut agir maintenant il
faut il ne faut pas attendre le mois de
septembre pour prendre les mesures
nécessaires c'est maintenant c'est dans
les semaines à venir que se joue
l'importance de la vague de la rentrée
c'est maintenant que se joue notre
capacité à maîtriser au mieux cette
nouvelle vague et pour cela nous
proposons que plusieurs
type de mesure soit mise en place
d'abord il faut que la vaccination
progresse de façon beaucoup plus forte
il y a aujourd'hui environ 34 millions
de français qui sont entrés dans la
logique vaccinale donc qui ont reçu au
moins une injection donc on peut estimer
que ces 34 millions de français
poursuivront et seront complètement
vaccinés à la rentrée mais c'est tout à
fait insuffisant
il est nécessaire qu environ 10 millions
de français supplémentaires soient
vaccinés dans les meilleurs délais pour
atteindre ses objectifs
toutes les mesures incitatives doivent
être mises en place en direction des
différentes catégories de population les
vaccinodromes rendent un service
important sont des lieux qui procèdent à
de nombreuses vaccination mais en
complément il faut maintenant développer
de façon beaucoup plus proactive une
politique d'aller vers aller vers les
populations qui vivent dans des déserts
médicaux ou à distance des centres de
vaccination aller vers les populations
qui vivent dans des quartiers dans des
villes dans des communes qui sont
particulièrement touchés par l'épidémie
et où la vaccination est tout à fait
insuffisante aller vers ça signifie
d'être dépassé le cadre de ce qu'ils
vont aller se faire vacciner qui sont
très volontaires pour aller chercher ce
qui sans être des opposants à la
vaccination mais ne font pas
nécessairement la démarche
non pas que les explications nécessaires
n'ont pas toujours atteint et dans ce
cadre là d'ailleurs les circuits de
soins usuelles
la santé ambulatoire la médecine
ambulatoire la médecine de ville doit
retrouver une importance première et
être en capacité de vacciner dans des
conditions les plus simples possibles
et puis il va falloir aller chercher en
particulier à développer la vaccination
chez les adolescents qui actuellement
allez-vous verte vous savez depuis le
mois de juin depuis quelques semaines
aux adolescents mais une politique
beaucoup plus active doit être mené en
leur direction
est ce que ces mesures incitatives
seront suffisantes
ça n'est pas évident mais en tout cas il
faut déjà les mettre en place pas
vaccinés au fil de l'eau mais aller
chercher et puis se pose la question de
l'obligation vaccinale et ce débat il
faut le poser franchement est
complètement la vaccination obligatoire
des soignants est un sujet tout à fait
légitime mais on peut vacciner les
soignants à 100%
on n'évitera pas pour autant le scénario
d'une quatrième vague l'impact de la
vaccination des soignants n'est pas de
nature à changer radicalement les
perspectives d'évolution de l'épidémie
donc c'est un débat légitime nous sommes
nous pensons que avec l'obligation
vaccinale chez les soignants doit être
faire l'objet d'une décision rapide et
que ne pose pas de problème particulier
mais au delà il faut poser la question
d'une obligation vaccinale en
particulier nous disons sur les classes
d'âge intermédiaire parce que nous
constatons dans les données qui nous ont
été transmises que que nous nous
publions que la classe d'âge des 18 59
ans est très contributives à la
circulation du virus est beaucoup trop
peu vaccinés
à l'heure actuelle est donc pour qu'une
décision soit prise il faut qu'elle soit
prise rapidement c'est-à-dire d'ici mi
juillet et donc nous souhaitons que soit
saisie
le haut conseil de santé publique
et en vertu du code de la santé publique
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales du sénat est fondé à
procéder à cette saisie est elle de
saisir a donc le haut conseil de santé
publique d'un avis sur la question et
j'ai écrit au premier ministre jean
castex par ailleurs pour lui demander de
saisir la conférence nationale de santé
notre principale instance de démocratie
sanitaire
lors du rapport la commission denquête
au mois de décembre dernier avec mes
collègues sylvie vermeillet catherine de
roche
nous avions regretté dans un autre
rapport la mise à l'écart au long de la
gestion de l'épidémie de nos instances
de démocratie sanitaire
eh bien nous souhaitons que la
conférence nationale de santé soit saisi
par le premier ministre et qu'elles nous
rendent un avis sur cette question
tout ceci dans les meilleurs délais afin
que mi juillet une décision puisse être
prise après que le débat ait eu lieu de
façon la plus complète possible donc
l'obligation vaccinale l'incitation puis
l'obligation vaccinale pardon sont un
élément important de cette stratégie
et puis deuxièmement la stratégie tester
tracé isolément tant que l'épidémie est
un niveau assez bas doit être mené de
façon efficace et avec remontée des
chaînes de transmission afin de pouvoir
les rompre de façon plus complète
alors c'est théoriquement le cas depuis
aujourd'hui mais nous avions constaté
lors des épisodes précédents la gestion
de l'épidémie et en particulier à l'été
dernier lorsque pareil l'épidémie avait
atteint un niveau bas que cette
stratégie qui était théoriquement mise
en place en pratique était inefficiente
et nos auditions à l'époque elle avait
parfaitement démontré avec une capacité
à identifier et à interrompre seulement
un cinquième des chaînes de transmission
on ne peut pas répéter la même
incapacité je dois dire et donc nous
appelons
l'exécutif à mettre en place de façon
beaucoup plus opérationnels la stratégie
tester tracé isolé et troisièmement il
nous faut mener une stratégie ambitieuse
de dépistage en milieu scolaire comme
vous le savez les enfants de moins de 12
ans ne sont pas éligibles à la
vaccination aucun vaccin n'est autorisé
à l'heure actuelle sur cette tranche
d'âge et pour autant contrairement à ce
qui a pu être dit à certains moments le
virus circule bel et bien en milieu
scolaire et donc entretien on va dire
kloster permettant dans un deuxième
temps la diffusion du virus dans
d'autres catégories de la population
l'étude qui nous a été remise et se
penche particulièrement sur cette
question du dépistage en milieu scolaire
et s'appuyant à la fois sur des
modélisations et sur des expériences
d'autres pays
cette étude démontre qu'un dépistage
itératif bien mené c'est à dire de façon
systématique hebdomadaire voire
bihebdomadaire par une méthode simple
non invasive qui est le test salivaire
est bien que cette stratégie était à
même de réduire fortement la circulation
du virus et donc elle est un outil
important pour encore une fois
transformé la vague en vaguelettes et
donc nous appelons à ce que le ministère
de l'éducation nationale ne poursuivent
pas dans ce qu'il a fait ces dernières
semaines et ces deux derniers mois
c'est-à-dire une politique tout à fait
parcellaire aléatoire et un peu
incompréhensible en la matière mais
qu'il prépare pour la rentrée une
stratégie ambitieuse de dépistage en
milieu scolaire il serait souhaitable
d'ailleurs et pardon parce que je
reviens un peu sur le sujet de
vaccination mais que en ce qui concerne
les adolescents
les services de santé scolaire soit
préparée pour qu'à la rentrée il soit
dès la rentrée en capacité aussi de
vacciner les adolescents qui n'auront
pas été vaccinés
pendant pendant l'été voilà en gros
l'essentiel de de nos recommandations
donc le volet vaccinale est une
politique volontariste pour permettre
que la vaccination progresse plus
rapidement et contribuer à ce que nous
atteignons le seuil d'immunité
collective en utilisant une politique
d'aller vers 2e pilier la stratégie de
dépistage et en particulier en milieu
scolaire et tout ceci en saisissant
rapidement les instances compétentes
pour qu'elle rende un avis et qu'une
décision soit prise d'ici mi juillet sur
ses différents volets encore une fois si
nous agissons maintenant et fermement
nous pouvons viser une circulation
minimale du virus nous pouvons éviter de
nouvelles mesures restrictives à la
rentrée nous pouvons éviter la fermeture
des écoles
nous pouvons éviter que un nouveau
couvre feu viennent interrompre la
reprise des activités culturelles et de
notre vie sociale
nous avons cet enjeu entre les mains et
nous appelons le gouvernement à s'en
emparer de façon ferme afin que notre
pays puisse poursuivre sa vie économique
sociale culturelle que nous soignons ne
soit plus saturés que de nouvelles
formes graves du coc vide soit évité
c'est possible c'est réaliste mais ça
nécessite qu'un ensemble de décisions
soient prises
voilà merci
eh bien je cède la parole à celles et
ceux qui souhaitent poser une question
ou faire une observation si certains
d'entre vous
souhaite poser des questions surtout
n'hésitez pas
je ne vois pas de questions on sait que
bernard jomier a été parfaitement
convaincant et complet et bien pas de
regret et une deuxième tentative
ainsi à il ya eu un rôle de gestion oui
bonjour stéphane de ardoz pour le
magazine terra gora vous appelez en fait
elle ne auquel n'oubliez sont quasi une
quasi obligation vaccinale
ça veut dire que vous envisagez des
mesures coercitives pour faire respecter
cette obligation qu'elle quel serait le
pendant de cette obligation et les
diverses mesures que vous souhaitez
mettre en oeuvre la question de
l'obligation vaccinale
le débat a pris une tournure étonnante
j'allais dire dans notre pays je
rappelle que l'histoire des maladies
infectieuses et dense et riche
d'infection dont la maîtrise a nécessité
à chaque fois un arbitrage entre les
choix individuels que nous pouvons faire
tous et toutes les uns et les autres
pour notre santé et l'intérêt collectif
et c'est à partir à chaque fois d'une
analyse de santé publique qui se base
sur une volonté toujours de respecter
bien sûr chaque individu mais de
protéger la collectivité que des
décisions peuvent être prises sur
l'obligation vaccinale
il y a deux ans le parlement a délibéré
sur l'extension de l'obligation
vaccinale à 11 vaccin chez les enfants
pourquoi pour mettre un terme à des
pathologies qui provoque qui provoquait
qui provoque encore d'ailleurs quelques
centaines de formes graves chaque année
voire quelques dizaines et que de façon
extrêmement large
malgré des oppositions tout à fait
entendent abl ces débats ont donné lieu
à un vote qui a été large d'approbation
de ses obligations vaccinales
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés à une
situation où quoi qu'on ait pu en dire
une grande partie de la population a
compris l'intérêt de la vaccination pour
soi même mais pour les autres aussi nous
ne pouvons pas libérer notre pays de la
menace de nouvelles contraintes sur
notre vie sociale culturelle économique
si le virus continue à circuler comme
ils circulent et comme il va aussi
reculé de façon plus importante à la
rentrée or nous avons un outil qui est
la vaccination
la question de savoir si l'incitation
moi je nous partageons cet adage qui est
répété que nous avons nous même porté
lors du rapport la commission denquête
notamment qu'il faut toujours mieux
convaincre que contraindre mais il est
légitime que la question la contrainte
se pose quand il y à un risque que le
pays et des personnes dans notre pays
soit victime du virus alors même qu' on
a la capacité de ne plus en être victime
je rappellerai que des personnes
vaccinées ne sont pas protégés à 100%
dans les modèles les plus positifs la
protection est de 95%
c'est à dire que vous pouvez être
vaccinés et vous pouvez malgré tout même
si le risque est beaucoup plus faible
que si vous n'êtes pas vacciné contracté
le virus et faire une forme sévère
il ya dans les hôpitaux en réanimation
c'est exact des personnes qui ont été
vaccinées mais asie sont en proportion
beaucoup plus faibles que celles qui
n'ont pas été vaccinés et si l'on veut
protéger tout le monde est bien seul
l'immunité collective
elle est une protection à 100 %
il est donc légitime que ce débat soit
tranché
nous sommes dans une démocratie après
consultation des instances de démocratie
sanitaire
et c'est pour cela que nous disons la
conférence nationale de santé doit être
saisi par le premier ministre et après
avis ça me ça nous paraît nécessaire
également bien sûr du parlement mais il
faut aller vite il faut que le débat
soit partagé faut qu'ils soient portés
et notre point de vue est très claire il
faut renforcer les mesures d'incitation
et d'aller vers mais la question de
l'obligation vaccinale n'est pas une
question taboue elle ne pose pas de nat
1 tu aux libertés individuelles qui ne
soit pas contrebalancé par l'intérêt
collectif
on peut regretter que cet intérêt
collectif soit insuffisamment défendus
merci je donne la parole
olivier monnot de libération p bonjour
question en fait je voulais savoir à
quelle classe d'âge le brigadier
vaccinale dont vous parlez s'adresserait
vous 18 59 mais dans votre rapport vous
parlez de 24,59 est par ailleurs sur les
écoles j'ai vu que vous parlez pas du
tout de la ventilation par exemple à
mettre en place dans les écoles alors
que le haut conseil à la santé publique
depuis un petit moment maintenant
recommande que tous les lieux
accueillant du public et une ventilation
adaptée à la pandémie que nous
connaissions et au risque de
transmission pareil aéro socialisation
et donc je voulais savoir pourquoi vous
en prenez pas merci alors concernant la
deuxième question je crois avoir
mentionné mais peut-être que j'ai trouvé
un trou involontaire mais je crois avant
de mentionner le fait que la mise en
place du dépistage itérative venait en
complément des mesures sur la qualité de
l'air qui faisait déjà l'objet de
dispositions réglementaires alors mal
appliquée oui ça j'en convient tout à
fait avec vous effectivement l'aération
est une mesure simple les capteurs de
co2 qu'un certain nombre de communes
d'ailleurs on finançait de collectivités
territoriales sont des outils tout à
fait utile et ccd montrer ça fait écho
phénomène d'aérosols isation dans la
transmission du virus que qui est
maintenant bien établie comme étant un
phénomène majeur en milieu clos de
transmission du virus
donc je pensais l'avoir mentionné mais
oui vous avez tout à fait raison de le
rappeler c'est un c'est un volet qui est
important je nous nous insistons sur le
dépistage itératif parce que nous les
recommandations que nous prononçons
aujourd'hui nous les asseyons sur des
données établies et scientifique est
celle que l'étude anrs cnrs pasteur nous
produit or nous n'avons pas procédé les
chercheurs n'ont pas procédé à
l'établissement de nouvelles données sur
la question de la qualité de l'air dans
les écoles mais sur celle du dépistage
itératif voilà pourquoi nous insistons
sur ce point et ce sont là de nouvelles
données
sur votre première question sur les sur
les tranches d'âge nous constatons que
nous prenons nous avons pris en compte
vont étudier avec beaucoup d'intérêt la
vie du cce du comité national d'éthique
sur la vaccination notamment des plus
jeunes bons et nous donnons nous
partageons l'idée que nous ne retenons
pas l'idée d'instaurer une obligation
vaccinale chez les 12 18 ans le csn
disait que c'est une tranche d'âge qui
est qui n'a pas de haine qui ne souffre
pas directement de l'infection par le
virus et qu'il y aurait une question
éthique qui se poserait à instaurer une
obligation vaccinale dans cette tranche
d'âge
alors que les plus âgés qui eux sont
vulnérables au virus ne seraient pas
vaccinés
c'est une réflexion tout à fait
intéressante on peut toutefois noter que
le fait de dire que les plus jeunes ne
sont pas des victimes directes du coc
vide et tout de même prête à discussion
on va dire puisque quand un enfant ou un
jeune attrape le virus et qui le
transmet et qu'un de ses parents
lui fait une forme sévère du virus
d'abord il en a des conséquences
directes pour sa vie personnelle et que
par ailleurs la circulation du virus au
milieu scolaire entraîne des fermetures
de classes voire fermetures d'écoles et
que ça a un impact direct aussi sur les
enfants mais bon nous ne pensons que sur
les 12 18 ans il faut mettre en place
une stratégie très incitative un plus
incitative il faudra proposer la
vaccination dès la rentrée scolaire dans
les établissements scolaires à cette
tranche d'âge et qu'il faudra auparavant
pendant l'été aller vers les adolescents
pour les inciter à se faire vacciner
pour ce qui concerne les autres tranches
d'âge la tranche effectivement des
intermédiaires on va dire jusqu'à 59 ans
et est une tranche d'âge qui contribuent
de façon importante à la circulation du
virus donc ça aussi c'est les données
que nous que nous publions qui ont été
publiés et cette tranche d'âge est à
l'heure actuelle insuffisamment vaccinés
on est bien en dessous de 50% du taux de
vaccination sur cette tranche d'âge donc
la question de la vaccination une
vaccination plus importante est de
l'obligation vaccinale est une question
qui se pose pour cette tranche d'âge et
nous paraît qu effectivement sous
réserve de d'une consultation quand une
fois des instances que je ne rappelle
pas une telle décision pourrait être
pour être privilégiée pour ce qui
concerne les plus âgés les taux de
vaccination actuels sont beaucoup plus
élevés et l'intérêt d'une obligation
apparaîtrait beaucoup plus faible voilà
alors en termes de légitimité
le débat est strictement le même que
pour la tranche d'âge en dessous un
gilet les éléments du débat sont sont à
peu près à peu près les mêmes mais en
tout cas l'intérêt l'effet serait
beaucoup plus limité du fait des niveaux
de vaccination déjà atteint merci je
donne la parole à solvay gaudeloupe de
des échos elle a pas de son
alors on les la question comment donc je
pose bois la question de solvay god luc
des échos au rapporteur
comment faire pour améliorer le tester
tracé isolé alors la stratégie tc tracé
isolé quelqu'ait été mises en oeuvre
donc jusqu'à aujourd'hui jusqu'au 1er
juillet viser à ce que les personnes
dépistées positives soit interrogé sur
les personnes qu'elles ont avec qui
elles vivent à qui elles sont en contact
pour aller leur dire bon on va on va
vous proposer un test pour voir si vous
même vous êtes positive ou pas elle ne
visait pas à remonter les chaînes de
contamination c'est à dire interrogée la
personne sur les contacts antérieurs
dans les sept à dix jours précédents
pour aller chercher ces personnes et
remonter les chaînes de contamination
depuis le 1er juillet je veux nous
prenons tout à fait acte que la cette
stratégie de remontée des chaînes de
contamination est officiellement mise en
oeuvre nous attirons l'attention sur le
fait que de façon opérationnelle
la stratégie tester tracé isolé avait
été mise en place d'une façon tout à
fait défaillante
elle a été donc abandonné dans les mois
précédents parce que le niveau de
nouveaux cas journalier était trop
important et que les capacités en
opérationnel en personnel n'étaient pas
là quand on a vingt ou trente mille cas
journalier on est incapable d'aller
contacter chaque personne et de procéder
à ce travail
rappelez vous que le chef de l'état à
l'automne dernier quand il avait parlé
des mesures qui amènerait à lever le
second confinement disait on reprendra
cette stratégie quand on aura moins de
5000 cas par
jour elle n'a jamais été reprise de fait
depuis puisque le gouvernement
l'exécutif s'est accommodé d'un niveau
de circulation du virus beaucoup plus
élevés jusqu'à jusqu'aux dernières
mesures de confinement au mois d'avril
et que suite à ces mesures et le
phénomène de re d'une courbe qui repasse
en dessous de 5000 cas journalier tout à
fait récent maintenant nous pouvons
effectivement reprendre cette stratégie
et nous devons la reprendre mais nous ne
devons pas réitérer les erreurs
précédentes qui ont été commises
il faut donc un dispositif qui soit
réactionnelle un dispositif qui remonte
les chaînes et qu' un dispositif qui se
déploie sur les trois piliers de la
stratégie tc tracé isolé
donc on teste ont tracé on trace en
remontant des chaînes de contamination
et on procède à partir de là à la mise
en place des mesures d'isolement qui
permettent de rompre les chaînes de
contamination donc notre alerte est
juste de dire un
cette stratégie est importante parce
qu'elle est très contributive dans la
rupture des chaînes de transmission et
il ne faudrait pas faire du tout
vaccinal non plus attention hein tout
misé sur le vaccin
certes si dans l'idéal 80 80 % la
population et éviter vacciner 80 % plus
les 20 à 22% qui ont contracté le virus
on est à l'immunité collective mais on
sait que ça va être extrêmement
difficile et même l'obligation vaccinale
n'est pas une garantie
d'atteindre de l'immunité collective ce
qu'est ce que démontre à chaque fois
l'obligation vaccinale quand elle est
instituée et on peut faire aussi
référence à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur les onze vaccin obligatoire
de l'enfant les données dont on dispose
et je n'ai pas vu celle de l'an de
l'année dernière mais les données
antérieures dont on dispose montrent une
progression de 2 à 3 % du taux de
vaccination ce qui est important 1 3%
mais ces quelques pourcents on gagne on
fait pas un bon un bond qui est on
n'atteint pas 100 % des personnes parce
que il ya une obligation vaccinale et
notamment parce que je reviens un peu à
une question précédente
la question n'est pas d'aller mettre en
place des mesures de coercition
ce n'est pas comme ça que le débat doit
doit se poser ce n'est pas notre ce
n'est pas notre rôle
mais donc les outils du dépistage qui
soit le dépistage des tarifs dans les
écoles la stratégie tester tracé isolé
puis bien sûr le respect encore du port
du masque en intérieur et c'est donc des
mesures dites non pharmaceutiques sont
toujours des éléments constitutive
important de la maîtrise de l'épidémie
est abandonné tous ces éléments-là
contribuerait à relancer l'épidémie donc
voilà tester tracé isolé ça a été mis en
oeuvre
l'été dernier et sa haine était mal mise
en oeuvre ça a été un échec
nous avons simplement à ce que ce soit
mis en oeuvre avec les moyen adéquat
avec les moyens des caisses d'assurance
maladie et des personnels qui ont été
formés et dans une dans un dispositif
qui soit efficient c'est à dire que
ondes s on a le résultat rapidement
très vite on rend donc les chefs de
contamination et on met en place les
mesures d'isolement nécessaire merci je
demande d'ailleurs aux journalistes
quand ils interviennent s'ils peuvent
vraiment allumé leur caméra
ce sera plus simple je donne la parole à
frédérique prabonnaud de france
télévision je sais pas si vous
m'entendez pas sûr on vous en
je voulais juste avoir une précision
mais je pense que vous en avez un peu
reparler là sur la tranche d'âge pour la
vie la saisine du haut conseil à la
santé publique juste être sûr c'est sur
la tranche d'âge 18 59 où c'est plus
large que ça la question vous avez posée
au conseil de santé publique alors la
saisie du conseil de santé publique
portera sur sera plus large porte sur
les mesures d' obligation vaccinale
donc c'est à dire au delà de cette
tranche
nous on est on fait cette préconisation
de éventuellement de privilégier ce
ciblage parce que les données nous
semble nous montrer qu'effectivement il
ya un retard à la vaccination sur cette
tranche d'âge quand vous comparez par
exemple aux adolescents elle a démarré
rapidement en fait depuis que la
vaccination a été ouvert aux 12-18 ans
immédiatement on a vu un nombre
significatif d'adolescents se faire
vacciner alors il faut voir dans les
semaines à venir parce que il faut qu'on
arrive à progresser
vous verrez dans les courbes où vous
avez vu dans les courbes qu' il ya des
multiples hypothèses qui ont été établis
en gros en dessous de 30% les faits
totalement insuffisant il est réel à
partir de 50 % de la tranche d'âge
vacciner voilà l'idéal étant encore plus
50% ça paraît tout à fait atteignable en
en étant incitatifs en étant
volontariste en la matière sur la
tranche d'âge intermédiaire
effectivement la progression est très
faible et donc c'est là où il ya une
interrogation qui est particulière mais
encore une fois notre rôle n'est pas
nous sommes des parlementaires nous
sommes là nous sommes ni une instance
d'expertisé scientifique
nous ne sommes pas une instance de
démocratie sanitaire nous sommes par
contre une instance essentielle dans une
démocratie qui est de veiller à ce que
l'intérêt général soit préservée et que
d'éventuelles mesures qui seraient
imposées
populations soient discutées soit
débattue devant les instances concernées
voilà c'est le sens de notre démarche
il n'ya pas pour nous de tabou il ya
pour nous un objectif qui est d'éviter à
notre pays une nouvelle vague encore une
fois qui est des impacts sanitaires
économiques sociaux et culturels et sur
les enfants voilà que voilà ce qui nous
ce qui nous guide et donc c'est en ce
sens que nous saisissons le haut conseil
de santé publique pour qu'ils se
prononcent sur ces questions merci
dernière question a priori virginie
bagouet de l' agence presse médicale si
vous voulez bien mettre votre caméra
bon alors je
buts rapporté répondra pourquoi ne pas
obliger au delà de 60 ans la vaccination
alors que l'étude de pasteur montre que
les plus de 60 ans non vaccinés qui
représente seulement 3% de la population
pourrait représenter jusqu'à 35 % des
hospitalisations
nous ne disons pas qu'il faut pas
institué l'obligation vaccinale
nous nous posons encore une fois le
débat et jeux pour ça fait quoi la
question précédente de madame prabonnaud
nous demandons au conseil de santé
publique son avis sur l'ensemble des
tranches d'âge et pas simplement le sur
la tranche d'âge intermédiaire mais nous
constatons simplement que le taux de
vaccination atteint dans cette tranche
d'âge est déjà très élevé et que si
on peut gagner quelques points par
l'obligation vaccinale nous n'y voyons
pas d'arguments à opposer mais
constatons simplement que l'expérience
de la vaccination des obligations
vaccinales montre qu'il y a tout de même
un niveau qui est difficile à dépasser
que vous n'arrivez pas à vacciner de
toute façon 100% d'une tranche d'âge et
donc pour protéger chacun encore une
fois il faut atteindre un niveau général
de vaccination qu'ils soient le plus
élevés possible parce que pour protéger
100% d'une tranche d'âge il n'y a qu'un
seul outil c'est l'immunité collective
et donc l'objectif c'est l'immunité
collectif et ça nous rappelle aussi que
l'analyse par catégorie et évidemment
intéressante et fondent beaucoup d'
approche mais que nous formons une
collectivité et que deux au delà de nos
âges respectives de nos vulnérabilités
respectives de nos vies respectives
un vaccin délivré à une personne protège
les autres personnes et donc que la
question si on veut bien considérer
l'intérêt général et l'intérêt collectif
et pas seulement des conséquences pour
nous mêmes à chacun d'entre nous
individus eh bien on doit aborder au
delà des différentes tranches d'âge
la question de la méthode a usé pour
atteindre l'immunité collective et
atteindre cette circulation munich est
minimale du virus donc ce n'est pas une
objection à l'obligation vaccinale chez
les plus âgés c'est juste un constat
on va dire d'efficacité d'efficience
bien s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions
on va conclure cette conférence de
presse
je n'en vois pas merci à chacune et à
chacun de vous et à très bientôt pour
d'autres propositions sur d'autres
thématiques liées à cette mission
d'information merci bonne journée
[Musique]